Chris Weber NBA on TNT analyst he'll be
calling tonight's blockbuster Bucks
Rockets Russell Westbrook's Houston
debut that's at 8:00 Eastern and then
our good buddy Reggie Miller will be on
the call Clippers at the Warriors at
10:30 Eastern and c-webb joins us on the
program how are you Chris how are you
I'm doing okay let me start with the
fact you're doing the Rockets who do you
think leads the NBA in scoring this year
oh man I think I think Harden
you know you look at the top I think six
seven seasons it's will like five times
then Michael Jordan then Hart as far as
the highest scoring averages for season
and so he was trying to get 40 in three
seasons there okay but what what role
does Westbrook play and how does Harden
get him or keep him happy
okay so let me talk to you like a friend
like matter analyst okay from your
friend understands in his dance
think about it man you want to play if
people don't like you and they hate your
show and then you have a boy and he has
a show and they hate his show and all of
a sudden both of you have a show on the
biggest platform are y'all gonna kill it
cuz everybody ain't doing you know you
can split up you can do it in and man if
I was Westbrook I wouldn't shoot the
ball one time all season averaged 30
assists and just say shut up everybody
and let my boy get MVP or you know so as
a fan as a fan of the X Hooper's that's
what I hope to see I hope to see those
guys define change whatever narrative it
is have fun to find a new role for
themselves and have fun in Houston is
what I plan for doing that as my friend
Reggie Miller says he can go and go he
can go bad real quick and so those
that's that's what's so fun about
tonight you know is you know hard and I
think is right about the narrative on
very honestly on not wanting him
necessarily to get the MVP or tired of
the way plays I don't like the way the
place that is so ugly with his team him
going up against after the kupo who
played so great last year and then we
kind of saw his weaknesses like like
really just glaring weaknesses once the
playoffs came in
final round and they tried to make him
shoot jump shot so how does he improve
so if I'm Westbrook in those guys I just
try to play as fast as I can
let harden do his thing one on one and
if I'm Westbrook and I get the rebound
everybody put in your track shoes we're
going to go we're going to play two
types of ball in the same game and you
know maybe maybe that could work and as
a fan I hope it's a lot of fun to watch
but it could definitely go the wrong way
fast
you had the pelicans in the Raptors
opening night and I want to I'm gonna
paraphrase what you said and then you
can clarify that Xion williamson didn't
play and you think that he's healthy but
this is load management is that a fair
assessment of what you said no and thank
dance no so we were going to break and
it's always crazy when you go to
breaking expect the timeout and they
call it and you can't finish that's not
what it is at all what our stand was the
narrative on him is that he's unhealthy
that he's injury prone and if you base
that on him missing five games in
college I don't know how you can do that
and say he's injury prone he bumped
knees and a preseason game in Vegas
Griffin said there's no need to play you
anymore why would we even risk you being
injured that's what I was going to as
far as the narrative so he was not hurt
in summer league he was not hurt in
summer league that's not the reason why
he didn't play herdy surfers no they
pulled him out being extra cautious
which they should and so him being hurt
now is a whole different story I've had
a torn meniscus and so him being out now
is just a whole different story and so I
was just trying to piece together the
narrative that listen he's not been hurt
his whole career it's not been a total
injury of he weighs about 280 right and
he's eight percent body fat
this is what David Griffin told me if he
gets down to the Reaper or six percent
body fat he'll still be 265 and that's
kind of the quandary with him is that
he's so muscular I was told that the
stress test that they do when they put
you know the clips on your heart and
have you running on the treadmill yeah I
was told from pelicans officials that
they couldn't even get a stress
because he kept running and was like you
got what you need yet and he's like
laughs and running on the treadmill and
they're like no you got to keep going so
his body didn't even get to the part
where it was stressed in the stress
[Laughter]
incredible athlete so I didn't have time
to say all of that but that's kind of
where I was going he's he's definitely
hurt now he has a torn meniscus he had
surgery but he was not hurt
okay and thanks for let me clear that up
as far as the knee itself because that's
that's your plant knee when you're going
up to dunk you know that's all this
explosion there and you're coming down
on that knee as is this something that
it will will be there you know I don't
know if it's gonna be our thright is
session or what you know I don't know if
it's a bigger thing than that and and
you know being in the Hall of Fame of
knee surgeries myself I I wondered about
that that plant knee and you know the
way he plays is this gonna be a problem
throughout his career
Danah such a great point I often wish I
would have hurt my right knee because as
a right-handed player my left knee is my
plastic and it made me run funny it made
me jump terrible it really ended and
hurt my career end so if you're a
left-handed player you do not want to
injure your lightening and so I agree
with you that it could be as simple as
irritating me tendonitis for his whole
career or it could be oh we better keep
an eye on this because it can it can and
I do believe it's in that space of it
could be totally healthy or we don't
know but it being a plant near being
that he plays with such force I was told
that he jumped 44 inches with no shoes
on I've never seen a guy like take a
vertical touch with no shoes on I can't
imagine that so the athlete that he is
is so incredible I don't know if we've
seen this and I think to compare him to
Charles is a little unfair because even
though Charles was heavy he had a
different type of body and it would be
interesting to see how he handles that
the injury and the league you know you
saw guys coming out getting 50 last
night and playing hard and it's going to
be tough for him to come back and make
an adjustment after he had a rhythm
during the preseason and then the miss
these games and they kind of try to come
back and catch up
gonna be you know tough for him so
hopefully that doesn't put more stress
on his body as well he's Chris Webber
NBA on TNT analyst Michael Jordan said
recently Steph Curry's not a
hall-of-famer yet you know Mike what do
you think he's getting at here do you
think he really thinks he's not a
hall-of-famer Dan you had such a great
context on sports and I don't
necessarily like what Jordan did but
like we we in sports now have such a
thing of going he's a hall-of-famer like
I've heard that about some quarterbacks
and stuff like their third year like I
thought that was blasphemous only
because like you still got to do it and
and the great ones will do it like the
wink that Jordan had to smile to the
camera you know to me that was an MVP to
an MVP saying yeah I want to see what
you do now that your boys are gone I
want to see what you do now that there
is no Durant and now that there's no
klay Thompson show me that you're the
MVP even in the bad year so many of the
MVP when you heard show me the MVP of
your team doesn't make the playoffs show
me the MVP if the team does so right now
we're giving away all these rewards
based on two different seasons three
different seasons and the game being
totally different and comparing them to
the greats because they never do that in
baseball like I never hear somebody say
oh man I'd take judge over ty cobb any
day I never hear that and they have the
real analytics and the numbers that go
by this so first of all of course
Curry's the hardest okay do you think we
need to like he's not in the Hall of
Fame yet needs a Hall of Famer but you
know yet when when Jordan said yeah
that's what I took it as and hopefully
is it hopefully he's not hating on Curry
because Jordan doesn't need to hate on
anyone in my opinion he's he kareem of
the greatest of all time but i think it
was more maybe than narrative on you
know sports collective just what i'd
like to be do you think curry sends a
message when Golden State plays
Charlotte just to remind Mike of how
good he is
oh yeah but I think that's what mike
wants I think this Mike can't play
that's all he wants to do and I love
Curry's response curry said well curry
got it because Terry said you didn't ask
him will I be in the Hall
that was a different question not do you
think curly be in the Hall of Fame he
said no Curry's not a Hall of Famer yet
no I like his little coy with that but
yeah he's gonna hit you know his
Charlotte with a hot because of those
comedies when I watch the Lakers opening
night against the Clippers I couldn't
help but notice it felt like LeBron was
deferring to Anthony Davis now I don't
know if that's just hey during the
regular season starting the season I'm
going to play nice
come postseason Boggs gonna go through
me but do you think LeBron is at the
point in his career where he is the
second option or is going to be the
second option for the Lakers I hope so I
mean it's been 17 18 years nine finals
all the things that he's done I've said
this all preseason that if I were LeBron
I try to get a be the MVP if ad gets the
MVP that means a B is doing all type of
incredible things and you would tend to
think LeBron getting a little rest
because the playoffs is all that matters
the bran does not have to prove one
thing to anyone and if it's only about
winning a championship then who cares
about the regular season let's get home
court advantage
let ad be MVP and then you be MVP in the
playoffs which is what you are when the
greatest players ever so I think that
but your question yeah yeah man it's not
did you see how did you see guys getting
up in them Klein I'm like one of the one
of the greatest signs of a player
getting older there's other players you
can see in other player's actions that
they are coming athletes play like no
one was afraid of LeBron no one
they didn't come double him they knew he
was going to pass when he got to the
hole he he has to LeBron has to have
nine layups seven layups to get you know
25 now those type of things so yeah it
is definitely slowing down but if it's
any player that it should slow down for
it's LeBron and we don't want to believe
it because he's kept defying time and
space and his play in his age and his
body but it's going to catch up sooner
or later and with guys like Kawada have
the same side same body same height that
can jump with them play defense is going
to it's going to be a little tougher
yeah it's gonna be tougher this year you
sold on the club
purrs being the best team in the NBA
yeah hope you won't know why yes they
are group they are the LA high hemas and
I should they are like a group of hyenas
like trying to just take food like the
energy you can't buy those personalities
that's that's not like you can't teach
those personnel you can't teach the
personality at blue that's been a score
all his life they wanted to come off the
bench or the fellas that play hard or
Patrick Beverley that everyone hated and
all this and now they love because they
see that he's just a fighter and so I do
believe in them because they play
defense every night I could see them
going over 13 from the three-point line
and playing great defense you know so I
do their defense travels their heart
travels and coach Doc Rivers he's one of
the best hike men on the sideline and
the good guys ready so yeah I do
I do like I like their chances this year
Wow alright are the linkers the second
best team in the West no I think I think
you still have to look at Denver Denver
has the deepest team I can remember that
in my playing time and the benches that
I've seen they have the deepest thing
that I can remember and I think they're
going to be a hard off the Joker he
doesn't have to score or he can get 14
points in the fourth quarter and 20
assists I mean the way that this young
team plays together their coach they can
play fast they can post up they can slow
it down they have veterans you know the
pressure we're really letting them off
the hook by not trading the expectation
because them being second in the West
last year first in the West last year
they've only gotten better and to me
they should have an advantage even over
the Clippers because they have a little
more chemistry they've had more time to
go I know well you have the Bucks and
the Rockets tonight and the Greek freak
feels like he's saying all the right
things
staying in Milwaukee do you think the
Greek freak is in Milwaukee with this
plane with this next contract
no no I'm not one for short answers but
no I don't I don't I don't see it I
played in a small market and I know that
you have to have a really really
brilliant relationship and I think the
next two years if they have a bad season
what does the media do one of the people
there do because it's funny thing about
small market teams and I think Kevin
Durant will tell you this is that when
you win for a small-market team if you
stay there long enough they forget that
there's small market and you leave and
you reminded this year for OKC you keep
Chris Paul and we'll show you what city
are so yeah I think you know I think
it's a delicate balancing act and he
says all the right things and I really
truthfully wouldn't be surprised I love
how I love I love his personality he's
like I was I didn't want to work out
with guys and I'm competing against what
am i doing that for like what what is
this isn't a co-op where we work out
together like you don't need to know my
secret I don't need to know yours or
things like that so I love how he
doesn't do the group buddy workout he's
not buddy-buddy with all him so that
makes me say yeah he can stay in his own
place and I care about it but I will say
gets cold in Milwaukee and you know
there's a lot of the place by the way
Vince Carter is three years younger than
you and that's crazy right it is and
Chris he I don't know how he done I
watched him in the preseason the other
night against the Knicks and he's I mean
he's become a very very good three-point
shooter and he's still doing it like we
marvel at Brady what Vince Carter's
doing is more incredible than what
Brady's doing his Vince is going against
these young pups who were 22 23 he's old
enough to be somebody's dad out there
Brady gets all that protection Vince is
out on the floor going up and down with
these guys no way later first of all
what this is doing is incredible but
Vince was doing incredibly he's planning
to get the young boys he's not getting
chased down but you're right and
wouldn't it be awesome if he was in the
dunk contest this year
okay do you think Saiyans in the dunk
contest oh would you let him if you're
the pelicans oh yeah oh yeah you're not
gonna get hurt in the dunk contest hey
guys have done contest after every
practice
yeah but he's coming off surgery though
Chris oh yeah but I mean but you know
you're talking about ten jumps at the
most if he's playing if he has played if
he plays three weeks into it four weeks
into it if he plays in December oh yeah
that's why come on I need to see him
that young kid from Miami and then let's
get Vince Carter back in because I'm
telling you the one thing about this is
so incredible is that you're right he's
doing it and the hardest thing about
getting over older is recuperating so if
you give me two weeks I can maybe do a
doctor too
if you get Vince to three weeks oh my
god I guarantee that he can jump like
this young still for two or three dunks
and it'll be it'll be incredible so
hopefully we get all three of those and
that would be great if Vince was there
and Zion was there but did you ever look
at spot and go how is somebody that
small duncanon people mess but in high
school and ask them could I touch his
cash wait wait you see spud Webb you're
in high school and you wanted to touch
his cabs a haircut or a ball patch on
the side I don't know but I did it I was
a man everything he did yeah oh yeah oh
you bring it every time you're on Chris
great to talk to you have fun with the
game tonight we appreciate your time as
always thank you that's Chris Weber for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]